Chuck D rapper actor producer and leader
of the group Public Enemy and part of
profits of Rage yeah are you an actor I
have too much on respect for that's been
what salute to you I've been a fan long
well thank you chunk it's good to have
you in and I like a make it I mean be
accepted to come in to Dan Patrick well
I know you love sports yeah but if I
said you had to choose between music or
sports you could only have one in your
life well because I couldn't play you
know I was like definitely is gonna be
music cuz I'm my voice I wanted to be a
sportscaster you did yeah you know
listen to Marv Albert and yeah you know
Lindsey Nelson and Bob Murphy and Jever
host and sports show host ah I've done a
couple you know what shows like popping
in and popping out I did uh for that
Network ESPN I did the alley special
kind of like you know I've been asked to
do some things who did you want to be
growing up like chip I'm the chip off of
his block and he was a sports fan and
you better follow the teams that he
followed so I born in a Flushing in 1960
in the shadows of the World's Fair which
had chase Stadium and now Citi Field for
something you know and um Mets fan you
know and they were bad back then too
yeah but you know I mean the National
League didn't have a team and then
everybody black in New York followed the
Dodgers and then a little bit of the
Giants never the Yankees because they
were the last to have a black player or
really a significant one else Howard
they kept Victo in the minors forever
and people like what but how big was
that to you or your dad growing up what
the Yankees were doing what the Yankees
were doing in the cities they weren't
yeah that they were one of the last that
was big because everybody immediately
every black person followed you know
Brooklyn Dodgers and Jackie Robinson was
like this the magnitude of Jackie
Robinson this was just too
just kind of almost like forgotten and
he was this major and it still had
remnants going into the 60s and the 70s
when I was growing up Jackie Robinson
was on my book reports it was like he
was like hero I was like you could not
get Jackie Robinson out of your whole
life front of your DNA yeah and then my
father you know of course everybody was
the Dodger fan you said yeah one day
Jackie Robinson came to my school him
and Campanella and gigantic guys came in
so what something are you still a Dodger
fan at all they don't know no not know
but you know the fact that your dad was
a Dodger fan that didn't you know at all
once they once they laugh okay then
everybody assumed the National League
Metropolitan's
and everybody that says all yeah Mets
and quote this is really a New York
Giants yeah but but it's also that this
comes from the Giants in the those
pinstripes came from the Yankees and the
blue came from the Dodgers but all these
sports fans just don't know these things
and your Willie Mays fan who couldn't be
yeah oh my heroes Roberto Clemente why
Roberto cuz he transcended sports oh but
he did with yeah well off the field and
we knew he was the unbelievable
humanitarian from the outside looking in
they didn't have as many detailed shows
back in the day but you knew that
Roberto Clemente especially when he died
that he was you know how was New Year's
Eve I think then he died yeah it was
significant but I remember watching him
and he played with a style and he had
Flair yes and he had there was something
about how he did everybody else was
playing rock and roll and he was playing
jazz his arm was unbelievable the way he
ran had a great smile and there was that
Pittsburgh team he had pop star Joel doc
Ellis first all-black team yeah starting
lineup I should say yeah and so we knew
this stuff as as kids and was
significant to us athletes spoke to us
entertainers spoke to us and it meant a
lot in a lot because we wasn't in woven
into society so these things were how
foundation you know Spike Lee says it
best in his movies as he comes out
let's similar but I mentioned that if I
looked at the lyrics to your music back
in the late 80s it's appropriate now mmm
unfortunately but one thing about it
older people pass on new people come in
you want to get rid of the stench of
that hovers over institutions and music
is one of those things that can always
be a universal language and cross the
time lines the gender lines the barriers
the John Roos and come across and that's
what we do at prophets our agent and so
yeah it's not the same story because
we're in a new time where everything
changes so but some things remain the
same you got to be adamant about you
know addressing it but why be kind of
combo platter with Rage Against the
Machine Cypress Hill and you know Public
Enemy Tom Morello looked at the
monstrosity of what was happening in
2016
and Tom said I got to do more than just
tweet about and he called what would be
a taskforce of revolutionary minded
forward artists you know who are
fearless in saying and doing things and
and create profits or rage you know with
all that you have to be also badass on
the stage we have to train to perform
and and and just begin to like say well
we don't care if you like it or not we
will convince you that this performance
and what we have to say will at least
have you thinking it if you think is
messed up the world ain't gonna fix
itself
you have to unearth the world shiver
fear for your life with Public Enemy we
show no fear completely you don't think
for stupidity yes you fear for ignorant
but you gotta do what you gotta do you
gotta you gotta you know you gotta
perform you have to be on your TV show
you have to take callers you have to be
in the audience sometimes you got to
take public transportation uh fear is
not the way we should live our lives you
know there's a lot of people fearful we
it just to keep it music wise we think
that bands and artists out there should
be fearless at least saying what they
Leigha not trying to follow the
marketing person or the record company
or that's what it is now well how would
Public Enemy be today with the way music
is the way it's sort of a we manufacture
pop stars if we came out today yeah we'd
be profit rate you know yeah it's like
uh we'd be prophets of Rage you know
making banging songs out of fearless and
I am probably gonna be released a song
this past summer we gave it to 750,000
fans so I mean look we're worldwide and
you music is the universal language it's
just starting to happen with national
sports in this country where it's just
be being able to become worldwide when
the dream team was talked about as being
this world phenomenon we in music
already without all here they come in
new to the world they're fresh fresh
world puppies using their passports we
have just played stadiums in Barcelona
and here comes the dream team
and so now National Sports USA sports
are like now they're like worldwide love
us the World Wide Web and everybody got
gadgets in their pockets they could tune
in and catch the show and so on and so
ok we're more round together as people
let's try to see if we can transfer
peace and great understand it's just
that the epicenter of gun massification
happens to be you know the United States
of America with Trump Otis wait is that
that sounds like the name of a song da
mama lyricist so I mean people have you
know and we have a lot of people
worldwide smdh in there like what's
going on there so we have to you know
work our way I think thinking globally
and acting locally is the thing that
saves us
he's Chuck D he's rapper producer don't
call him an actor and if the leader of
public in his early morning but it's
prophets of rage so you have members of
Public Enemy Rage Against the Machine
and Cypress Hill I need those members
yes you can it's the one and only
fantastic Tom he's one of the great
guitar players in the world he has
reinvented a way to Qatar
you know does its work all you do is
hear him on the goes to Tom Joad with
Bruce Springsteen right he he is the
stir the straw that stirs the drink okay
so Tom's in it you have be real the
Almighty be real from Cypress Hill he is
the charismatic leader microphone a a
shaman a one you have DJ Lord one of the
great turntablist in the world as Tom
Marella makes the guitar sound like a
turntable DJ Lord makes the turntable
sound like a guitar and you have are the
great Timmy Comerford Timmy see who the
bass plays him is he's the spiritual
leader you know and then you got the the
god of hard drums Brad Wilk and together
those three create those magics that
that magic and I'm we have we play or
with all sports heads right and uh where
the defense myself
Timmy C on bass and Brad well we played
a back we're like mmm you know we
covered the back the front guys a detail
or tom morello and be real they're the
offense and we take the stage just like
that we have theme music do people
recognize if they hear your voice or
they see your what would they recognize
more when I first started my career they
say here comes this six-foot-five
250-pound dude and they said oh that
voice and you're not six five no no but
that voice that voice arrives before you
do yeah it arrives before I did in a rod
for my father my father could yell
across the town and he said did you hear
me call you and you could not say no I
mean he was shake the panel's you know
he passed last year you know so you know
he would shake the panel's and he was
like you'll just beat me down just don't
yell at me so you would be very happy I
was on your show
oh that's cool we'd be very happy we'll
continue with Chuck D I want to ask you
about Colin Kaepernick Muhammad Ali and
the connection between those two
growing up with Eddie Murphy and Charlie
Murphy and rap jeopardy okay yeah
will you do it well if they don't hang
me out there fritzy
fritzy you can help Chuck T okay yeah
okay but keep it painless he did not do
any lyrics when you saw him did he Chuck
no no no he was very kind at the doorman
okay does it bother Goldie Goldie came
with us he said I want to travel with
you he is give a damn about me he just
wants to so when you hear people come up
to you and they do the lyrics to your
songs that Bobby I feel as good as Bob
Dylan
I don't think Bob feels good about that
I think he does no I don't think so you
probably won't show it but you'll pay
he'll take that quiet can Fritzi do you
for you next course we're on DirecTV
DirecTV it get in touch with BMI we
gotta have a one-time-only here at one
time only how much this just maybe one
verse cost yeah five we got to pick one
welcome back Chuck D will play rap
jeopardy we'll talk about Colin
Kaepernick and fritzy does Chuck D for
Chuck D right
[Music]
Chuck D staying with us course leader of
the group Public Enemy but the new group
the supergroup is called prophets of
rage you got members of Public Enemy
Rage Against the Machine in Cypress Hill
the debut self-titled album prophets of
rage available tomorrow is there gonna
be a tour played in front of 2.5 million
people before our first record oh yeah
North America South America and we just
completed north and south Europe 2.5
million people and it's real I mean it's
it's like you know what I told my guys
in Public Enemy who by the way you know
inducted into the Rock and Roll Hall of
congratulations it wasn't like oh here
comes the rapper's we're gonna dilute it
no and you know we made innovation but I
told about guys I said this is great
guys I'm going to the all-star game
though me and DJ Lord you didn't want to
go to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
ceremony no no I'm saying in in jest I'm
saying
professore rage is like going to the
limo okay remain with the Utah Jazz oh
wow all right y'all talk about Rudy
Gobert Rudy Gobert yes um you grew up
with Eddie Murphy in elemér down the
street right down the block
well both of them tremendously funny
Bernie's do you think was gonna be the
one who would make it between those two
well Charlie was older than me and I had
one of my homeboys you know was in the
class and they would come back with the
exploits of Charlie Murphy every day
saying what he's did in class so
therefore I was a fan of Charlie Murphy
like 75 76 and I knew Eddie Murphy
because Eddie was always funny and he
would had great impersonation but he was
always a ladies man too who come to the
parking with shoes and pants and we were
we were we were dirty guys with mud on
our sleeve I had you know that but Eddie
was always a smooth dude yeah but when
he broke though well we knew it when he
was first no were we when Eddie Murphy
went big in the hood is when we saw him
on Saturday Saturday Night Live and he
had a skit we bought this big box if God
made us
equal here to get y'all one of these and
and we were like yo he's on Channel four
words that and we say what
like that's when Eddie Murphy made it
big and then you saw my mom I think um
in the mall Roosevelt Field he said oh
that's nothing I'm gonna make the movies
and then 48 hours happening he had to
move out of Long Island when you get out
of there when did you know you were
famous how would I know I was famous am
I I always tell people I'm infamous I
think um certain things touched me like
my first year playing Nassau Coliseum
and also the garden when you go back
home and then you realize you're selling
out these places that you used to go to
as a kid that's got to be yeah yeah
playing the garden was like kind of
surreal the first time 87 it's like you
know in the beginning of my career when
you look at and I've been on 106 tours
30-year vet in the beginning looking at
all those people in perform and they
look like pizza one big pizza or big rug
in playing stadiums were you - I was
like what is this dude way up there
getting out of this so you know I mean
so I mean this this is like I said it's
like it's like icing with a cherry on
top plan would profit the rage and the
best players in the world doing what
they do I'm the weakest link yeah but if
I'm the weakest link it and one nights
it's a problem it's pretty good problem
yeah where we were very competitive
there they're all at the top of their
game so I wanted to ask you about Colin
Kaepernick I mentioned this at the
passing of Muhammad Ali yes I think
there are a group of athletes were a
group of athletes who didn't understand
what Ali was really all about especially
at that time yeah but but now they
understand and I think it kind of
something clicked with a lot of athletes
where they said you know if it's lebron
or dwayne wade or you know LeBron has
been incredible he's been tremendous as
always the best players look if the top
players don't take a stand and throw
their fists up in the air to fight for
for what's you know what's right and
also to transcend their sport a little
bit and take a note from the athletes
from the past it makes it difficult for
someone who is trying to negotiate their
position
position their place in a job so the top
players have to look out in the 60s you
had the top players look out whether it
be hourly whether it be a Bill Russell
and Jim Brown uniting with them and
making concise statements athletes in
the sixties you see even write books
yeah and I'm not the books that kind of
happened today where I got a write a a
writer that's gonna write what I think
is on my mind
the guys like Wally Jones I'm over Wally
Jones he wrote a book 76 years car yeah
yeah wal I yeah and then athletes in the
sixties in the 70s although they didn't
have microphone time because it you know
okay they thirty points 15 rebounds six
assists and they would give him the mic
for about five seconds well mama
Muhammad Ali grabbed the mic and they
think our lives is I okay you're gonna
respect what I respect athletes if they
couldn't even make a verbal statement
they changed their name
Kareem did yeah I mean they changed it a
name to Muslim Islamic names they even
make a powerful statement before the
world be freeze and then they're more
free you know Metta World Peace and
things like that but it's Kaepernick
making a difference of course because he
resonates there's so many people that
don't have a voice and then we we might
take sports and entertainment a little
bit too serious who's who seriously to
the point we don't think that athletes
should be able to speak in this country
and and that's a disservice to the power
that these people have because there's
so many people are voiceless and we're
in a situation right now where they have
not just so much on the increase and
people on the peripheral edge I've heard
people talk about all these NBA players
that come in and they went through all
this money well a black athlete that
comes in is as an extension of a family
that might not have that doctor and
lawyer when it comes down to his cousins
nephews and and that's just the ketchup
of time or being held back where where
you know that all right you're that guy
you have to look across maybe three or
four families or maybe two or three
generations
support and that's not to say that
everybody or people of all the color or
white folks don't have it rough in their
families but there's enough of a head
start of people who had their own
businesses have own homes
also have a solid a place in society of
governing their area or education that
black folks are still trying to catch up
with look when I was five years old then
they passed a civil rights bill that's
some damn nerve to say now you guys are
civilized it's like a hundred years
after slavery you know the catching up
after the scarring other people might
take two hundred three hundred years so
what Colin Kaepernick is doing he's he's
focus he has a focus on saying this has
to be said whether you feel it or not
because they didn't feel those athletes
in the sixties and they and they were
kind of coherent on what they were
talking about today people have a
movement called black lives matter that
people on outside my said oh it's a
violent movement but you're not taking
everything in the count in consideration
on how it's bringing people to the
forefront of being in doing better all
right we're gonna take a break we'll
come back for its he's gonna do Chuck D
for Chuck D rap jeopardy as well oh and
you said cube did it - yeah cube did it
he didn't want to but then he did it and
then I think cube is the dude that has
two brains in his head so if he couldn't
be good now he was good at it he just I
think and once again it's got to be in
the form of a question this is jeopardy
okay Chuck all right so don't do what
Kubek you made the mistake he wouldn't
say in form of a question and that's the
dude that doesn't make any mistakes
yeah well but did this messed around got
a triple-double I don't buy that at all
Chuck right come on I would torch him I
would George I would torch ice he's my
brother brother he didn't get a
triple-double though and we know that he
did look but yeah he's a decathlete in
music and rap I give you that I give you
that he's what you call what we are like
in acting Bojack bo Jackson love music I
in acting as well all right welcome back
rap jeopardy with Chuck D and Fritzi
does Chuck D pretty Goldie I did I got a
photo with Goldie there you go Goldie
again yeah we'll come back come back
after this in the Dan Patrick show is
Chuck D stand with us till the top of
the hour so slow on it man the crew Dan
Patrick that's my my to live crew over
there that's sort of live crew truck is
part of the supergroup prophets of rage
members of Public Enemy Rage Against the
Machine Cypress Hill the debut
self-titled album prophets of rage
available tomorrow all right we're gonna
do rap Shepard oh are you ready okay so
now it's got to be in the form of a
question your answer you know how this
works I'm Alex Trebek all right you
ready okay here we go
Terminator X speaks with his and that is
correct what our hands
I feel like gave me the like the second
grade it's a TV show Chuck nine-one-one
oh yeah okay we'll take that one
most of my heroes what is a stamp
what is don't appear on no stamps Chuck
we're not let me go to the judge no
we're not gonna take a good beat is for
Sonny Bono beat is for who is Yoko own
that is correct yes yo what is bombers
this show there you go look at that
there you go now we have some bullies
that was like drinking my own vomit
[Laughter]
[Music]
Curtis Curtis blow used to take his girl
to see them go against one another
Fritzing what a Knicks
pretty what is tiny
all the Pearl who are tiny and Earl the
Pearl when Daryl Mac throws a curve
you've got the nerve to turn this fritzy
I'll throw a curve you got the nerve to
make a triple play now let's take a shot
see but you wanted it and I gave it to
I'm bringing you noise right now
throwing fastballs by you roll with a
chip on his shoulder
it's like Jamie Moyer throwing fastballs
by you with a chip on his shoulder
Eric B holds the microphone like this
rock him line Oh fritzy
I'll hold the microphone like a grudge
man they're gonna they're gonna kick me
out of the shot out of the rap always
they're gonna take you out of the
rock-'n'-roll Jose because I'm focused
on these prophecies okay all right
fritzy we gotta give him one more one
quick one in the show Slick Rick was
here when he ran into Tony the Tiger got
on the D train at 250 so a pretty girl
so so I sat beside I bet your aunt Rory
was Tony the Tiger whoa
the band is prophets of rage the
self-titled album prophets of rage
available tomorrow Fritzi can you give
me a little Chuck D to Chuck D as we say
goodbye and this is the reason why we
make lyrics oh no you're like fritzy can
actually do them you focus on now here
we go fritzy all right Fritz you got it
caught in the middle and not surrender
and I don't run for the sake of riddle
in some claim that I'm a smuggler some
say I've never heard of you're a rapper
girl or false media we don't need it do
we it's fake that's what a B do dig me I
see that tape recorder and I grab it no
you can't have it back silly rabbit I'm
going through my meteor assassin Harry
Allen I gotta ask him you'll have it
you're right are we that type the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience